Es sollte ihr Paradies werden:
eine Villa im bulgarischen
Dorf Mogilishte.
Vor acht Jahren kam das Ehepaar Eschke
aus Deutschland hierher,
kaufte für eine bescheidene Summe ein
großes Anwesen und wollte hier alt werden.
Doch dann kam alles ganz anders.
Die Kameras und die Alarmanlage …
[das] ist zur eigenen Sicherheit
für diebisches Volk oder Betrüger,
Abzocker,
die hier rumfahren, die ausspionieren,
weil die nicht anders weiterwissen
[als] zu stehlen.
Sonst könnten die nicht überleben …
Die Menschen sind arm hier?
Die sind arm – bettelarm, bettelarm.
Das Haus gleicht einem
Hochsicherheitstrakt.
Die Überwachungskameras
laufen Tag und Nacht.
Eschke traut kaum noch
jemandem in seinem Dorf.
Auf der Kamera eins seht ihr
dieses Grundstück vis-à-vis.
Die Kamera zwei bringt unsere Orangeria,
oder Gewächshaus auf Deutsch.
Der Aufwand, ihr Eigenheim zu schützen,
ist riesig und kostet
– Geld, das die Eschkes nicht haben.
Denn ihr Leben im einst so günstigen
Bulgarien wird immer teurer.
Ihre ursprüngliche Kalkulation reicht nicht
– nicht in Bulgarien und erst recht
nicht mehr daheim in Deutschland.
Von 900 Euro kann ich daheim nicht leben,
weil ich muss rechnen:
Also, selbst die kleinste Wohnung
kostet so ... na, sagen wir mal 400 Euro.
So, da hab‘ ich auch noch
kein Wasser bezahlt,
da hab‘ ich keinen Strom bezahlt,
da hab‘ ich noch nichts gegessen,
da hab‘ ich kein Auto,
keine Versicherung, gar nichts.
Deutschland ist keine Alternative.
Aber in Bulgarien will Ralf Eschke
nicht bleiben.
Seine Nachbarn sind weggezogen
– viele davon Deutsche und Briten,
die wie er in großen Anwesen in
Mogilishte alt werden wollten.
Also ich fühl‘ mich jetzt wirklich einsam.
Denn auch zu Bulgaren haben
die Eschkes kaum Kontakt.
Tanja, die Verkäuferin des Dorfladens,
kennt Eschke zwar seit vielen Jahren,
aber sie ist distanziert.
Denn viel mehr als „Brot“, „Wasser“ oder
„Danke“ kann Eschke nicht sagen.
Was soll man da reden?
Ich hab‘ auch nicht so das Interesse
dafür und ich hab‘ auch nicht die Zeit.
Ich hab‘ dann angefangen, dafür zu lernen
und dafür hatten wir viel zu
viel Arbeit am Haus.
Auch nach acht Jahren in Mogilishte
leben die Deutschen im Dorf isoliert.
Wir grüßen uns,
das ist aber auch schon viel wert.
Es gibt viele, die grüßen nicht mal mehr.
Enttäuschte Hoffnungen.
Dabei hatten die Nähe
zum Schwarzen Meer,
das tolle Klima hier in der Region
um Varna und die günstigen Preise
die Eschkes einst für Bulgarien begeistert
– so wie rund 25.000 andere deutsche
und britische Rentner,
die hierher ausgewandert sind.
Jedes Jahr werden es mehr.
Doch wie folgenschwer diese Entscheidung
sein kann, ist vielen nicht klar.
Der Österreicher Manfred Schriefl
kennt das Problem.
Er leitet die Firma „Lebens-Residenz“
in Varna und berät deutsche Rentner,
die nach Bulgarien wollen.
Auch in diesem Apartmenthaus hat er
Wohnungen vermittelt.
Zurzeit ist hier ausgebucht.
Doch er warnt davor, voreilig im Alter
ins Ausland zu ziehen.
Sehr viele Leute werden auch
getrieben von der Vorstellung,
dass sie sich mit den möglichen
finanziellen Mitteln
hier ein goldenes Leben erkaufen können,
und enden dann sehr oft in einer Spirale,
wo das noch viel,
viel schlimmer für sie wird.
Wir haben einfach dann sehr oft Leute,
die nicht mehr zurückkönnen,
weil sie in Deutschland alles
veräußert haben.
Doch nicht alle sind unzufrieden.
Die 76-jährige Anna Lex aus Stuttgart
wollte mit ihrem Mann
auf dem Motorboot „Lara”
rund um Europa schippern.
Seit ihr Mann vor zwei Jahren unterwegs
an einer schweren Krankheit starb,
lebt sie allein im Jachthafen von Varna.
Ihr Boot und Bulgarien sind zur
neuen Heimat geworden.
Sie will hierbleiben.
Die Leute haben noch Zeit –
zum Reden zum Beispiel,
beim Kaufmann so ...
stehen bleiben und reden,
das gibt‘s in Deutschland alles nicht.
In Deutschland muss – also jetzt –
muss alles zackzackzack,
schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell [gehen].
Und das macht es dann liebenswürdig
und dann ist die Landschaft schön,
das Meer natürlich.
Für Bernadette und Ralf Eschke dagegen
sind das Meer und die Strände
heute kein Trost mehr.
Meine ehrliche Meinung: Ich würde nicht
nach Bulgarien gehen.
Ich ... Wir wollen weg,
wir wollen nach Ungarn.
Doch in die alte Heimat Deutschland führt
für die Eschkes wohl kein Weg mehr zurück.